no clay is all about the Angelo and
update luli inside shoebox defendant
when he gets advance shot clock at six
Ruslan's their Beverly the close here
comes the engine
if it rebound by weapons in that
Robinson a season ago
[Applause]
the ants all seven of Golden State's
points in his warrior debut Leonard it's
a five-step curry
have to do it stops at the defensive end
10:01 beautiful Pixies
Gibson's ago trade using your games
ticket or get this they have bicycles
that way here in theory
[Applause]
pick your poison five quick points for
Lou Williams Jacob Evans in takes a
open/close out of Cincinnati Lucci
[Applause]
curry last year finishing fifth in
scoring in the week
he's got Hiro on the edge recognized
that mantra is Harold leaning to his
left let me give him a little bit of jab
step knocked down a three here create
that separation number one bench score
last season
[Applause]
you like this all season between
D'Angelo and Steph your turn my turn 20
of the 27 points here by the backcourt
all these guys are long you could switch
everything
they're aggressive defensively pool with
a three wide for Golden State
curry you started three of nine in the
court of new T triple
basically the same in this game here
comes curry kicks it out to green Shama
to the Venge screen
Leonard with a step back over Pascal and
picked up by curry it goes ahead pass go
inside by the defense of the channel
against the two at the other end for
sweet Lou off the bench
hey mate excuse me you got 18
fancy moves my claw who's got 13 points
in the aforementioned eight assists
hurry up and try to find the deuce
picked up by Green and a lot
in the odd moment of this new building
as well
[Applause]
I'm out here by dog Kauai there's a
rifle shot
that's a three he's got four of them
[Applause]
school together
driving into the defense of Williams
counter the foul called on lose a bit of
experience
nobody the morgue egg curry gets a
turnover on a handoff
- go for the Clippers knees between
curly with a nice move to get by the
team that's - Incheon will be down there
by Robinson they come the other way and
queens of prison - with
yep Golden State shooting 37% tonight
Clippers is shooting 63% from the field
he's looking
put in by Glenn Robinson 15 threes in
this game for the Clippers it means that
I want you to be the greatest warriors
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content